hey what's up I'm Ryan I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for need for speed
in case you can't tell what I'm doing
this is my sort of ok Jesse Pinkman
impression [ __ ] right let's watch this
trailer that did sound anything like him
I spent two years thinking about one
motion in our world you always go back
you so know that's what I can't forgive
that's my boy yo T
I'm really happy home boys we miss your
brother Osama celebrate call up some
females you know any pretty ones like
your mama oh he took the bag down mama
what do you think you're told this could
put him away for life it's time we make
you pay but first we're gonna need a
fast car what'd she do
already doing this company that brought
in shreds Gracie is hard revenge mission
racing a passion that's higher
and I think that's Tobey Marshall
driving the chariot of the gods
I'm willing to give six million dollars
to anyone quit so stop to him lot of
cars are slipping this behind
yeah [ __ ] Highway Patrol
I can feel engines motor oil all
swirling together there's an APB out for
your arrest in Ted state [ __ ] it up so
nice cars
your mind looks a little generic doesn't
look that original but still looks like
[ __ ] testosterone-filled man got my
balls jacked up I guess what I'm trying
to say is it fills your testicles with
more semen